justement faisant à présent à la
mi-journée le point de la circulation
dans les départements sinistrés la
situation ne peut que s'améliorer dans
les heures qui viennent reste que nombre
de routes sont toujours coupées à la
circulation mais sur l'a7 ça s'améliore
quant au trafic ferroviaire la sncf
conseille toujours de différer tout
voyage vers le sud est certains tgv sont
bloqués olivier sainte-marie le point un
véritable déluge accompagné d'un violent
orage les habitants de la somme hier
dans le gard en v rik dans mon vécu un
véritable cauchemar
les dégâts sont énormes actuellement la
plupart des routes nationales et
départementales sont impraticables dans
le gard le vaucluse l'hérault et le nord
des bouches du rhône seules certaines
autoroutes ont pu être remises en
service la circulation entre lyon et
orange ainsi qu'entre orange et
montpellier a été rétabli hier soir
n'est ce matin la route entre alès et
nîmes est toujours coupée la circulation
reste vivement déconseillé dans le sud
est
difficile donc de circuler d'autant que
le réseau ferroviaire est encore
fortement perturbé dans le
languedoc-roussillon le trafic tgv est
toujours bloquée entre montpellier et
nîmes
la situation est inquiétante sur
montpellier nous avons des questions ou
des interrogations sur un pont à la
hauteur de lunel sur alès les ouvrages
d'art sont altérées ce qui veut dire que
nous avons pour plusieurs semaines de
travaux sur nîmes alès
actuellement la circulation des trains
corail et des ter à destination et en
provenance de la côte d'azur est
toujours suspendu
cependant les liaisons tgv ont repris
via avignon et marseille ce matin
soixante mille foyers sont toujours
privés d'électricité cent cinquante
mille personnes n'ont plus de téléphone
essentiellement dans la région d'alès la
situation ne devrait pas revenir à la
normale avant la décrue des eaux